[Música]
tudo bem que você gente é um ótimo eu
não os vejo
espero que vocês vejam é quando eu
comecei a pensar sobre essa palestra é
pensar sobre o significado que as coisas
têm na vida da gente falar sobre o
significado é muito difícil e aí o
quanto representa onde estava um evento
muito grande com 600 pessoas
e aí o superintendente desse evento não
é desse dessa empresa chegou falou com
as pessoas me conhecem e aí todo mundo
conhecia e logicamente é o
superintendente que não conhecesse
levantarem a mão de qualquer jeito e aí
ele saiu entrou - cerimônia cerimônia
chegou e falou assim alguém me conhece
uma pessoa de belo horizonte e conhecida
das rádios e aí metade conhecia e ele me
apresentou como lucas me apresentou
flávio tem um projeto social dentro de
áreas de prostituição dentro de
presídios e eu entro pergunta para as
pessoas vocês me conhecem ninguém
levanta a mão
foi gente será porque não quer se
entregar é é quando a gente começa a
pensar em áreas como essa que a gente
faz trabalhos como presídios área de
prostituição asilos
as pessoas começam a pensar em
sofrimento em dores em histórias que
remeta dores
eu comecei a ver também que há outras
possibilidades não só as dores dentro
desses lugares e eu comecei então a
tentar entender das pessoas
qual o significado que a vida tem para
elas
e aí eu queria que ela falasse olha
vocês estão nessa situação o idoso no
asilo é uma pessoa presa uma pessoa que
descobriu um câncer uma outra em
tratamento de hemodiálise e eu fui
buscar justamente respostas para poder
tentar entender o significado da vida
para essas pessoas
pra mim a vida tem um significado muito
forte significado é uma palavra
extremamente importante para todos nós
creio
quando eu comecei a dar aula 20 anos
completa este ano 20 anos de sala de
aula
eu entrei numa sala de aulas de manhã e
aí quando me apresentei para os alunos
eles me nomearam de tio flávio amado
era agressiva eu era 25 quilos mais
gordo era careca cabelo que eu tenho é
meu e eu não devo nada a ninguém eu
adquirir étapa guné até a empresa que
trouxe então quando a pessoa era mais
gordinha era careca pessoas pessoas
brincando e se protegendo já no sétimo
período de um curso irá atuar nós vamos
chamar de tio flávio o tio flávio foi
pejorativo
o tio flávio foi uma barreira ou uma
ofensa mas é interessante como essa que
é a vida né
a no relacionamento com os meus alunos
do tio flávio passou de ofensa de
pejorativo para a respeito para carinho
e esse nome tem um significado muito
grande para mim tem um significado muito
forte para mim
quando a gente pensa em significados é
justamente isso
a vida é uma semi hoje a gente vive de
semiótica e aí a gente pensa justamente
o que que é semiótica que é que esses
símbolos o que esses signos nos ajudam e
eu comecei a pensar nesses signos dos
projetos que a gente atua hoje a em 2010
nós criamos o tio flávio cultural ele
não é uma ong o movimento esse movimento
ele não tem finalidade lucrativa
partidária religiosa
nós somos hoje mais de mil voluntários
em 67 grupos 65 grupos atuando em 27
áreas diferentes
quando a gente começa a perceber que as
pessoas vão chegando para se voluntariar
também envolvendo o significado que o
voluntariado tem na vida delas
o que elas estão buscando ao procurarem
um movimento que trabalha em asilos em
creches é em abrigos e aí uma um poema
do manuel bandeira ele me chamou muita
atenção quando manuel bandeira fala
aquele poema do bicho esse poema eu
conhecia muito tempo e quando ele fala
sobre aquilo ali olha vi ontem um bicho
mesmo disse do pátio catando comida
entre os detritos quando achava alguma
coisa não examinava nem cheirava engolir
com voracidade o bicho não era um cão o
bicho não era um gato o bicho não era um
rato o bicho meu deus era um homem e aí
eu também comecei a fazer paralelos até
quando que a gente perde a nossa
dignidade e viram bicho
o que é é perder o sentido
e aí eu fui pesquisar com essas pessoas
o que elas tinham pra mim falar sobre os
sentidos sobre os significados
foi justamente conversando com os
meninos em abrigos que eu procurei pra
eles perguntar pra eles olha uma pessoa
que o pai ea mãe faleceram é quando eles
eram crianças ou que o pai a mãe ou
abusaram é qual é o sentido da vida o
que faz um menino de um abrigo um
adolescente num abrigo estar vivo querer
viver querer olhar pra frente
a vida já abusou tanto dele ele já foi
tão violenta dado porque ele quer
continuar
e aí uma das coisas mais interessantes
que houve foi justamente o seguinte eu
quero provar para as pessoas que eu
consigo eu quero provar para aquele meu
tio que me avisou que eu vou vencer
eu quero mostrar para as pessoas que é
possível que não sou um qualquer
eu consigo viver na vencer na vida o
significado para ele significa para o
menino de sete anos que eu conversei
semana passada é esse menino contando a
história dele sem provocar ele foi
contando que ele aos sete anos passava
fome
a mãe não dava comida pra ele e ele
ficava na rua pedindo as coisas
um dia ficou sabendo que um tio faleceu
ele foi ao velório do tio e aí sozinho e
aí o conselho tutelar pegou esse menino
eo levou para um abrigo e é esse menino
falou lá no abrigo que a maior
preocupação dele é que quando ele houve
fogos de artifício ele se preocupa com a
mãe porque ele não sabe se a mãe está
bem
eles projetam uma mãe que os abandonou
uma mãe que não os quis uma mãe que não
existiu
aquela mãe que eles queriam e eles
querem formar famílias que possam
reparar aquilo que eles não tiveram
eu fui conversar com os jovens e aí eu
encontrei nos jovens aprendizes dentro
do projeto flávio cultural uma dor muito
grande de pessoas que estão buscando
rumos mas às vezes são perdidas mas uma
delas me chamou muita atenção quando
estava dando uma palestra e ela estava
com a blusa de frio num lugar muito
quente e é aquela blusa de frio estava
tampando logicamente os braços e aí todo
mundo com muito calor ela com aquela
blusa de frio e ainda tinha um capuz
acabou a palestra eu tinha falado um
pouco de depressão suicídio essa menina
chegou perto de mim foi o tio flávio se
falou essa palestra foi pra mim não foi
pra todo mundo inclusive pra mim ela
levantou a manga da blusa e mostrou
diversos cortes no braço
levantou a outra manda mostrou diversos
cortes no braço
só que os corpos estavam cicatrizadas eu
lembrava se nós mas e tentou suicidar-se
tantas vezes assim a fonte o fla você
acha que isso é tentativa de suicídio se
acha que eu tentei tantas vezes e não
consegui
na verdade o fla deixou de falar o que é
isso
quando eu me corto eu tento passar pra
cá a dor que eu sinto aqui eu nunca
senti tanta dor junto com alguém quando
ela fala que tenta passar para a carne
que ela tem que cortar na carne para
poder amenizar a dor que está dentro eu
perguntei para ela com que a sua
esperança qual é a sua expectativa de
vida
a flor que as pessoas me vejam e olha só
no meio de alunos de ensino médio jovens
aprendizes
havia uma invisível assim como vários
existem na nossa vida que a gente vai
ser atropelado a gente conversa de manhã
tomar café mas a gente vai ser
atropelado uma frase de manuel bandeira
também fantástica quando fala que bicho
acostumado com a toca entrega com as
estrelas ea gente às vezes se acostuma
com as entre aspas desgraças
a gente ouve acha que é normal a gente
acha que as coisas estão acontecendo são
normais e quando a gente parar de achar
normal talvez a gente levante da cadeira
a gente enxergue que perto da gente há
possibilidades diversas para que a gente
possa começar a mudar o mundo não sei se
esse mundo grande mas pelo menos o nosso
mundo aprender com o outro eo mundo dos
outros
aprender com a gente eu fui perguntar
também para idosos os idosos a gente
hoje tem 18 asilos que a gente atende eu
fui perguntar para os idosos o que eles
sentiam muitos deles abandonados pelos
próprios filhos que eles sentiam queria
saber se era solidão eu queria saber se
era esperança e muitos deles falava
assim olha os filhos não vão visitar
mais a gente espera que pelo menos no
mês de maio eles venham mês de maio mês
das mães
só que muitos não vão a cinco anos
muitos
o visitam e aí eu fui procurar saber dos
próprios cuidadores das pessoas que
trabalham lá e elas falaram comigo
flávio
quando a gente chega para trabalhar
aquelas pessoas que já perderam um pouco
não perder a esperança
mas elas estão na expectativa de um
filho vi que não vai vir
aquelas pessoas projetam na gente
voluntários e funcionários no projeto na
gente o filho que abandonou e aí quando
a gente chega a falar que bom que você
chegou e quando a gente vai embora falar
mas já se acabou de chegar
como é que se vai embora tão cedo assim
e era justamente o final da jornada de
trabalho elas projetam nas pessoas vocês
que vão visitar asilos e que acho que é
só uma visita de levar um violão de
levar um abraço de sentar de entregar
uma fralda geriátrica
vocês não sabem o quanto que isso
completa a vida de quem está no asilo ou
às vezes sabem quando a gente vai
visitar outras instituições como
moradores de rua pessoas em situação de
rua a gente encontra tantas histórias o
tinha branca em belo horizonte onde as
pessoas vão para dormir
elas tomam carro é tão jantam tomam
banho dormem no dia seguinte tomou café
da manhã
ali tem várias e várias histórias ea
história desse rapaz
o edson é uma história que marcou muito
porque ele morador de rua pediu para ser
voluntário no tio flávio cultural e se
havia algum problema ele conheceu nosso
projeto do albergue e eu falei que não
havia problema nenhum ele fez palestra
com a gente dentro de uma pac um tipo de
presídio financiado ele fez palestra a
gente para jovens
só que ele começou a usar droga muito
cedo e essa droga impactou os rins e
quando ele descobriu que estava
extremamente dependente precisando mesmo
diálise ele foi fazer hemodiálise um mês
e meio depois de começar os trabalhos
voluntários
o edson no hospital do barreiro vem a
falecer e aí eu comecei a me questionar
assim como alguns amigos que conheciam e
que me apresentar a ele olha só o que é
que que a vida tem para esse menino um
cara que morava na rua e que perdeu tudo
a expectativa de reconstruir família a
expectativa de talvez não será aceito
pela família que ele abandonou mas a
expectativa de começar de novo de provar
para os outros
viveu quando a gente conversa com outros
tipos de públicos como pessoas que estão
privados de liberdade
uma pessoa chega perto de mim fala sente
flávio você vai conversar com preso
você vai começar com o bandido preso se
está agora mais bandido há cinco anos eu
faço trabalho em apac socioeducativos e
do sistema prisional e eu descobri que
eu não conheço um bandido o que eu não
entro na cadeia pra conversar sobre
crime sobre artigo eu não entro pra
conversar sobre bandidos
eu entro pra conversar sobre gente e
quando eu cheguei bicas 2 devido uma
grade 30 homens e ali a gente
conversando de igual pra igual olhando
os olhos bem próximo da eles chamam de
capa a porta da cela eu olhei pra eles e
falei olha eu acredito realmente que
bandido bom pra mim pra mim
bandido bom é bandido morto eles
assustaram e lost uma grade entre eles
mas é eles assustar obviamente e o que a
gente faz no nosso trabalho é justamente
isso eu não vou matar o bandido de
ninguém mas eu vou lá para fortalecer o
indivíduo pra dar a eles valor
suficiente referências diferentes pra
que ele entenda que ele pode matar o
bandido dele e devolver pra mãe o filho
que ela tanto espera
a gente conversa com gente eu não
converso com o bandido
quando a gente visita hospitais ea gente
visita alguns aqui em belo horizonte
a gente começa a perguntar para as
pessoas ao significado tem a vida pra
elas descobriu que o rio não funciona
precisa de uma hemodiálise vai ter que
sair de casa três vezes na semana para
poder fazer uma sessão de quatro horas
naquela máquina que invade o seu braço
suga seu sangue filtra e devolve
filtrado e aí eu perguntei para as
pessoas o que é que isso significa pra
vocês e eles falaram significa vida se
eu não sair de casa eu morro
algumas não vão fazer transplante outras
vão entrar pra fila do transplante é uma
fila mesmo mas eu comecei a pensar poxa
mas você não desesperou o lógico
desesperei
é lógico desesperei e aí eles vêm com a
obra esperança a gente tem esperança de
que consiga aprender a conviver com a
doença
a gente tem que ter esperança e quando a
gente fala de esperança eu falo também
das pessoas que a gente atende que são
que tem câncer
quando eu fui conversar com uma pessoa
que tinha câncer ela já teve quatro
afogamentos flávio a gente leva um susto
muito grande
só que o primeiro baque o segundo back
ou mas o terceiro que foi de mama
foi um susto pra mim ele foi avassalador
ele foi pesado e quando eu descobri que
tinha câncer
eu olhei pra aquele câncer de mama o
terceiro mas meu deus do céu eu já tive
dois e eu estou no terceiro hoje ela
está no quinto lugar dando conversei com
ela ontem para que ela falasse o
significado que a vida tem pra ela é a
fonte flávio
quando eu descobri o terceiro eu comecei
a perceber que os meus filhos tinham
perdido o pai tinham sofrido na morte do
pai
eu não posso morrer eu não posso morrer
eu tenho que lutar e eu falei mas tira
deus falei com todos eles falei com os
presos falei com os meninos do abrigo
falei com os moradores de rua tira deus
o que te motiva e ela falou comigo não é
por deus a gente não luta por deus a
gente luta com deus mas eu luto pela
vida eu aprendi que eu amo viver uma
palavra extremamente interessante essa
que está aqui esperança a esperança foi
que uniu todas essas histórias e as
pessoas tenham esperança quando você
passa na rua e vê uma pessoa morando na
rua
deitado ali ela tá com aquele carrinho
amarrado muitas vezes buscam um lugar em
que haja proteção porque tem uma câmera
que a protege ela tem esperança de um
dia poder mostrar para os outros que ela
conseguiu vencer a esperança move as
pessoas mas adoro essa frase quando um
professor pedagogo falou comigo que o
fla quando chegar para conversar com a
pessoa que mora na rua ou entregar uma
comida nunca entregam comida achando que
ele tem obrigação de receber porque você
tá fazendo bondade
pergunte a ele se ele quer porque olha
só que maravilha gente tudo pode ser
tirado de uma pessoa tudo é certa uma
coisa ali
a vontade de escolher sua atitude em
qualquer circunstância da vida e esse
cara que falou isso sabe o que está
falando porque viveu quatro em quatro
campos de concentração nazistas
aí vem esse provérbio chinês por onde
começar
gente eu apanhei muito até entender por
onde começar por onde começar uma
mudança de resignificação da sua própria
vida
eu achei esse provérbio que uma coisa
extremamente interessantes não adianta
com problemas em casa tentar fazer o bem
ao outro sendo que eu não consigo
resolveu da minha própria casa a minha
própria casa pode ser entendida como
parentes mas pode ser entendida como eu
próprio quando você pensa nesse
provérbio aqui que antes de começar um
trabalho de modificar o mundo é preciso
dar três voltas dentro de casa ou seja
se conheça e entenda
veja o que você tem veja seu potencial
seus problemas mas esta é a última frase
que eu deixo para vocês
entenda e construa o sentido da sua vida
entende construa a gente não está aqui à
toa a gente está aqui sozinho quando
todas aquelas pessoas que foram
pesquisadas por mim e eu perguntei que
significado tinha vida ela sempre
projetam alguém dentro do sonho delas
mas nunca estão sonhando sozinhas com
elas próprias em um filme chamado cartas
pra deus em que o que a criança ela
escreve cartas pedindo a deus que salve
que proteja as pessoas quando ela morrer
mas ela não pediu por ela pediu pelas
pessoas
a gente não vive sozinho e aí fazer
sentido na vida dos outros
uma mulher fantástica chamada li zhi da
silveira que peitou muita gente pra
poder fazer uma diferença no mundo
falava isso é necessário se espantar
indignar e contagiar
só assim é possível mudar a realidade se
você está sentado achando que você não
tem importância pra ninguém olhe nos
olhos de quem está do seu lado
estendo a mão falar de deus e carregar
bíblia não é suficiente faça com que ele
esteja presente acreditando ou não mas
em energia na sua vida e na vida dos
outros
isso não faz bem só para os outros
vai fazer um bem nome pra você valeu
gente brigadão e até a próxima
[Aplausos]